bonjour à tous je vous ai parlé il ya
pas très longtemps du samsung galaxy a6
et a6 plus qui devait sortir et
justement ça y est ils ont été
officialisés par samsung
donc j'ai pouvoir vous dire exactement
ce qu'on sait samsung galaxy a6 et a6
plus dans le ventre et on y va accoucher
samsung ne fait plus tôt un très bon
d'année un très bon début d'année
arrivé avec le galaxy à 8 et a8 plus
qu'il n'est pas sorti chez nous mais le
n8 est sorti chez nous avec le s9 et s9
plus qui prend tous sortis tous les deux
chez nous hélas le a6 et a6 plus qui
vient d'être présenté le début d'année
est plutôt pas mal les produits sont
plutôt séduisant et une fois n'est pas
coutume ce samsung galaxy à six élus
assistent plus sont plutôt cool alors
reste à savoir si le a6 plus sortira
chez nous j'en suis pas intimement
convaincu le a6 va arriver le assiste
plus amener ça fera comme le a8 le l8 on
n'a pas vu arriver le guide plus je
pense qu'il arrivera jamais donc on va
regarder un peu ce qu'ils ont dans le
ventre
ce qu'on s'est produit la fiche
technique bien évidemment g cloud
récupérer j'ai tout potasse et je suis
prêt et l'huile dans les starting blocks
pour vous donner toutes les informations
on y va maintenant vous avez déjà du
point de vue l'écran un écran infiniti
super amoled pas de notch samsung pour
l'instant tient bon résister ne met pas
note je faisais déjà fait une vidéo pour
vous dire qu'à priori on pourrait
peut-être le retrouver sur le s10 de
l'année prochaine pour l'instant rien
n'est sûr rester tranquille mais ces
galaxies a6 et a6 plus n'auront pas de
notch alors ils ont un boîtier en
aluminium au niveau des spécifications
techniques le galaxy à 6 à un écran de
5,6 pouces hd plus au format 1480 par
720 pixels c'est du super amoled ça je
voulais dit d'un autre côté le a6 plus
serein écran de 6 pouces fhd plus en
2002 120 par 1080 pixels
ils ont tous les deux un format de 18
points 5/9 côté caméra le assiste à une
caméra arrière de 16 mégapixels et
qu'une ouverture de f
1.7 assez lumineux ça fait très bien à
faire tandis que les assises plus un
double module arrière une caméra de 16
mégapixels et une ouverture de f 1.7 et
une caméra de 5 mégapixels ouverture de
f
1.9 on imagine très bien pour les faits
évoqués pour ajouter un flou naturelle
et non pas un flou logiciels à l'avant
vous avez sur l'a6 une caméra de 16
mégapixels et couvertures de f 1.9 et à
l'avant sur le a6 plus une caméra de 24
mégapixels une ouverture de f
1.9 alors côté processeur vous avez sur
l'a61 exynos 7870 octas core cadencé à
1,6 ghz
et sur l'a6 plus cet instinct dragonne
450 octas core cadencé à un gigahertz
vous avez 3 giga de ram progrès 6 4
gigas de ram pour le a6 plus haut niveau
du stockage vous aurez à priori soit 32
gigas 64 giga sur les deux modèles bien
évidemment extensible jusqu'à 256 giga
sur l'a6 étaient 400 giga sur le a6 plus
haut niveau la batterie c'est une 3000
milieu intérieur sur le a6 et une 3500
millions paire eur / le a6 plus les
tournois deux sous android 8.0 avec la
surcouche samsung maison l'expérience
lui
ils ont tous les deux du bluetooth 4.2
bond wifi ça ne vous ont pas ça ferait
un peu les spécifications vous avez la
reconnaissance de visage pour
déverrouiller vous avez le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui se positionne
à l'arrière de l'appareil au centre
juste en dessous du ou des capteurs
photo et vous avez mix by bixby qui vous
aide pour la traduction avec big
division vous avez aussi bixby ownby les
reminders indique dit pour l'instant
toujours en français il devrait arriver
dans la deuxième partie de 2010 8 donc
pour l'instant rester cool bixby vision
ça marche quand même plutôt pas mal ça
c'est vrai que c'est coûteux pour
traduire des textes traduire des textes
vous avez en chinois par exemple si vous
partez en chine que vous ne pouvez pas
dire le chinois ainsi qu'en tout cas il
mon cas je ne sais pas lire le chinois
bixby vision pourra vraiment vous aider
alors comme je le disais du point de vue
du début brouillage vous avez autant
d'empreintes digitales qu'on retrouve
comme sur les samsung galaxy à 8 et s9
directement en dessous du capteur photo
c'est quand même mieux
plus ergonomique plus pratique on va
moins se poser comme sur le suit
directement sur la lentille là c'est pas
terrible
un coup c'est mieux positionnés pas
encore complètement idéal mais il ya un
vrai pas qu'ils étaient faits en avant
cette année par samsung
vous avez aussi du son dolby atmo savoir
d'aubiac moss vous l'aurez uniquement
avec le casque c'est ce qui nous a
spécifié samsung
ils ont bien marqué en anglais
intentions de volières dolby atmos audio
fait pop t-il only of hedge funds only
voilà donc l'époque où ne cherchait pas
à avoir un hobby et mousse dans une
pièce il vous faudra forcément un casque
sur les oreilles se produira donc
renouveler et compléter la gamme à on a
vu le à 8 en début d'année la le a6 qui
arrive là les produits de la gamme à
2017 sont plutôt pas mal là on voit
qu'on va renouveler la gamme avec des
choses qui sont vraiment très actuel
donc ça ça fait du bien à savoir que la
gamme à de 2016 m
elle est encore actuellement
commercialisé chez samsung c'est pas la
meilleure gamme les produits sont pas
hyper hyper sexy mieux vaut aller si
vous voulez une gamme à un peu moins
cher sur la gamme de 2017
vous êtes déjà fait des vidéos pour
faire des comparatifs sur ses gammes de
samsung vous allez voir il ya des choses
qui sont assez intéressantes on retrouve
un boîtier en aluminium de choses que
plutôt sympa qui se tient bien alors à
choisir entre le a6 et a8 très
clairement je préférerais le a8 ne
serait-ce qu'au niveau design
après je dois reconnaître que par
rapport à la génération antérieure de
2017 ce à six de 2018 est vraiment sexy
d'ailleurs je sais pas il ya plusieurs
personnes qui m'ont mis en commentaire
mehdi pas sexy ça me met mal à l'aise ça
vous gêne quand je dis sexisme trop sexy
comme ta main si ça convient pas c'est
que si dit mon commentaire ce qu'il faut
que je dise à moi ça me ça me dérange
pas alors il sera disponible en quatre
couleurs alors on aurait le noir lors le
bleu est la couleur lavande un petit
violet très sympathique ses collants
sont pas disponibles forcément dans tous
les pays
je ne sais pas ce qui arrivera en france
affaire à suivre on le verra directement
sur le site de samsung pour l'instant
c'est un communiqué de presse que j'ai
reçu de la part de samsung avec cette
information là que je fais plaisir de
vous relayer dès aujourd'hui pour le
prix non plus j'ai pas d'infos alors la
gamme assez le moyen de gamme de samsung
sont pas les produits qui vont être les
plus chers ça on le verra dans les jours
à venir en tout cas on aura les infos
sur le site de samsung
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
aujourd'hui sur ces nouveaux samsung
galaxy à 6 à 6 plus je le dis une fois
de plus à mon avis lui assises plus haut
ne verra pas chez nous en france on
pourra le faire venir peut-être de
belgique
en attendant pour tous nos amis belges
parce qu'avec des mots c'est une chaîne
francophone je ne m'adresse pas là la
france pour les résidents français on ne
l'aura pas pour les québécois on devrait
pouvoir la voir pour les belges
on pourra la voir pour les suisses c'est
probable aussi dit moi d'ailleurs dans
vos pays respectifs est-ce que vous avez
le a8 plus de disponibles parce qu'en
france il n'est pas dispo voilà pour
cette vidéo d'annonce du samsung galaxy
a6 et a6 plus dites moi comment vous le
trouvez peut-être que vous trouvez bien
réussi est ce que vous trouvez que
samsung a fait un bon job sans ce
produit est ce qu'ils écoulaient ce que
vous préféreriez le18 walo est ce que le
v6 pourrait carrément vous tentez vous
ne marquez tout sans commentaire bien
évidemment on reste connectés
parce que vous allez voir il ya plein de
choses hyper cool qui arrivent sur des
produits tendances des produits tech
plein plein de choses et là je taf à
fond sur la rentrée du mois
septembre et croyez moi ça va envoyer du
bois restez connectés laissez-moi des
jolies pouces comme d'habitude et je
vous dis à très bientôt soyez sages
je vous embrasse pour les soins de vous
ciao
[Musique]